qué expectativas hay por la vuelta de la
juventud que ya está próxima a iniciar
la próxima semana así que si estás se
celebrará en colombia y es considerada
la carrera sub-23 más importantes del
país en ella habrá presencia de un
equipo francés y hablamos del team inca
que estará presente en esta ronda de la
mano del equipo de esteban chávez y su
fundación nuestro compañero juan
pupiales conversó con el director de
este equipo y esto fue lo que nos dijo
hoy en araña
el proyecto del cinca comenzó hace ya
cuatro años y hemos estado en contacto
con el ag2r y la mundial desde hace dos
años voy al
y ellos buscaban implantarse en américa
latina pero no tenían pistas a seguir y
es por eso que se acercaron a nosotros